tells gobert to clear it out
mitchell oh he punches it home
that's a big mistake and how about the
adjustment as grant comes over
step back three heat check three-point
ball game murray
into traffic tough step back because
that shot
mechanics is pretty and then obviously
the tough shot making ability
here's mitchell a chance to close out
the half with a nice layup
atoning for the turnover on that pass a
moment ago
mitchell coming up on the toyota
halftime
jay on db's today since the drag screen
mitchell splits it
up high in a terrific pyrotechnic
he's deserved it donovan mitchell
carried your team in the second quarter
do not relax don't take your foot off
the gas
keep attacking off the dribble and i
know he prides himself now on the growth
he's made as a passer
right now they need both got two elite
defenders on the
the los angeles clippers and an electric
player
in luka doncic what happens there
speaking of electric
he's got the wattage blowing right now
donovan mitchell with the floater
turnovers in the first half but just
screen and roll with rudy gobert the
footwork to check ball screen
mitchell rolls it in on the reverse and
again another rudy gobert screen
and this is the toughest shot i mean
he's driving two
in the second half compared to 18 and
half number one
speaking of paint inside drive at
donovan with 33.
settles for the three good just
behind the gobear screen
driving mitchell finishing 45.
just sets the perfect angled screen and
then you give this guy a window a seat
wow was that a backcourt that's what
quinn snyder was saying
murray for three got it matched here
again
exclusively two-man game rejects the
screen
puts the as good a start as he had he's
disappeared here a little bit
for the time murray butter hurry
around the oak screen hit him with the
hesitation move murray
oh he's on fire al murray has created
for you
he's got a longer defender on him than
joe ingles
mitchell downhill stopped on a dime no
change for murray
separation with the step back how about
that
ridiculous stop and pull into your jump
shot motion
[Applause]
murray got all the way inside great
left-handed move
but boy oh boy what a possession
three-pointer
jamal murray 12 pounds stronger than he
was a season ago in the playoffs
looking for atonement this year jukes
ingles and he has it working 33 in the
game
for jamal murray
mitchell with a little get back got it
a minute to go off the yoked screen got
free
raising up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
20 seconds to go mitchell on the drive
foul that they're gonna count the bucket
just adding to what has been a
spectacular day
yeah fouled on the gathered absolutely
fouled on the gather inside two minutes
remaining in the first half
step back and rattling that home
performance right now for utah
[Applause]
and mitchell the step back it's just
mitchell
getting all his teammates involved
hurry trying to answer and he does so
jamal murray
responds but man murray is saying all
right it's my time to go
yeah that time o'neil just a little off
balance but it was a handoff again
downhill utah jazz you lose a
heartbreaker in overtime this kind of
response has been impressive
mitchell for three i told you the ball
would come back
to mitchell when he had an opportunity
to score think about this last
game utah made 16 threes on 47
attempts they already have 18.
you need something and you need it in a
hurry heading into the fourth ottoman
mitchell
he takes the take advantage of the
three-point shot but then
on the deck on the attack the middle was
open he's 1-1 the first one was an
overtime win
and that was denver and jamal murray who
opens with the jumper
game two though inhales that rebound
ingles to mitchell good eye contact in
the hammer by donovan mitchell oh
donovan mitchell to get right behind him
easy pass easy play for donovan mitchell
inside you see the late rotation
by porter jr good cycle to jeremy grant
his three [ __ ] out
gobert couldn't grab the rebound but
here comes mitchell in motion
donovan mitchell all the way to the iron
to put it up an end
jamal murray downhill on bear right to
the rim
oh my god a right-hand spike
against a rudy gobery went right by him
well you do you do see it if he's that
far out on the perimeter his lateral
movement
go bare inside donovan mitchell likes
that porter junior matchup
his three-point stroke has been
incredible he's intelligent enough to
know to get himself on balance and then
make the play
donovan mitchell has had phenomenal
third quarters
he hits the three that's where gobert
was able to be open right in the middle
murray little floater down the lane just
what you talk about is what you do
you know on and off the court oh jokic
threw it right to mitchell the former
slam dunk champion
right hand tomahawk
[Applause]
a 30 spot and denver takes time
this time just a little bit of pump fake
a little bit of space and dunks on the
defensive player
that's a nice dark heap can you believe
that
be a decoy find an open man donovan
mitchell shakes porter and
perry's the jump this is where they want
to get him
rattled a little bit mentally yeah and
to really pass
shot clock ticks down to three murray
lets a runner pass
down it goes jam and now murray goes all
the way
murray scores and this is why coach
malone wants his team to secure the
rebounds not give up any offensive
rebounds
plumley finds murray shot clock down at
one it gets up in time and
counted this out oh
nice nice you freeze that big man back
there and because plumley's there and
you know if you pass it to him he'll
finish it strong
you have to honor that fake
he has left the bubble to seek a second
opinion
on his injury and hoping that ultimately
his right
knee gets healthy and and once he rehabs
and gets that second opinion we'll have
more updates
going under a minute in this second
quarter step back three murray hill he's
got another one
going back to the point the guys are
making
in atlanta at the half and just i think
we're hearing
more coaching of energy and effort as
murray scores inside
right about that spot that donovan
mitchell just cashes one in it's a big
deal
that's a big deal he had a couple of
jams and this one had one
right away as we started in the first
quarter here's mitchell taking on jokic
quick release on the lay-in tell you
what if i gave a team 57 points i want
to play you
every day at the playoffs because you
know you can light it up and murray says
yeah i can light it up as well the
beautiful shot from outside and again
largest lead of the game for the jazz
and now murray looking for a foul oh he
makes it he was looking for a foul and a
chance at a four-point play
hope you'll make plans to be with us
pooping every night here
in the nba bubble murray gets a friendly
bounce just a scoring machine right now
even more impressive than the dunk was
him catching that i mean
colbert is so short-handed down there
great pass right there by mitchell
thought it was too much on it
three-point answer on the other end
murray
is roasting right now denver down four
under five minutes to go in regulation
here murray fires
again and murray hits again
look at this pick out front the great
set by jokic
and he didn't get a charge on the way
you love that coach schneider told us it
was such a difficult decision because
he wanted to be a part of this playoff
run so he's
certainly a part of them getting here
for sure as murray hits a huge three for
denver
right back in it a nugget player in a
playoff game
mitchell all the way and gets it to go
nice shot clock down to four
mitchell has millsap on him he'll pull
up three and he hits a three
all the play and sometimes you just say
i'm the coach
but i can't coach this go do your thing
donovan mitchell
gets the big three and talks to the
camera has got to go quick
murray hits a long one here he'll have
50. he's sitting on 47 he'll pull
the three he's got the three 50-point
game
first time in history opponents score 50
apiece but this one
belongs to the utah jazz as they run and
it's been interesting
since conley has come back he just
hasn't seemed to be
into the offense he's kind of lost his
rhythm offensively mitchell steps into a
deep three
and buries it
mitchell around the screen hounded by
murray takes some contact
and he's headed to the free-throw line
[Applause]
well he gets in the lane murray holds
his
nicely done here comes murray slicing
his way through the defense against
denver
denver one of the best offensive
rebounding teams in the league
great save by millsap there
and he's going to try to walk it off
first field goal for millsap mitchell
got it
another look see jokic is up but he goes
the other way
drives away from the pick 17 of their 23
bench points
have come from clarkson tonight he has
been magnificent
murray taking flight puts it down boy
challenges gobert
at the rack to a dozen porter outside
murray
deep three get it
pass from porter murray steps into a
wide open
sister the night little give and go
action jokic back to murray
and that was a thing of beauty and then
a tough drive right here going at rudy
gobert getting to the other side of the
ring
there he comes down the paint knocked
out of his hands well played by dozier
outstanding individual defense by dozier
murray the relentless drive and he's
brought denver whipping form
here's a young guy pj dozier getting it
going with his defense great defensive
plays by pd
pj dozier murray inside incredible
jamal murray with a stroke of genius
majestic second round
here's murray off the inbounds splash
fourth quarter game five
mitchell you're getting right you line
the spin back
left he drives away from the pick and
gets to the basket
you've got to get him into the pick and
into the help of your big guy
murray and once again those two with a
postseason duel
make it 28 after that last sucker
mitchell
mitchell here just gets by everybody
half-hearted help by michael porter jr
this is donovan
mitchell you can't stay on the side
you've got to get your
body between him and the basket what a
finish
donovan mitchell unleashed loves to
finish with his right hand
on those floaters conley following up
his 26 point performance and look at
murray at the other end
here he comes again down the path
dropping a dime and grant blocked by go
bear
two to shoot murray shoots and he bears
murray a step back long two
mitchell is bumped
murray just taking donovan mitchell in
game four
forty tonight murray again
the mesmerizing talent of jamal murray
nine point denver lead so neil
and said we'll do the same thing that's
good defense by royce o'neil
and we will be watching brian anderson
chris webber jared greenberg will have
the call coming up next
on tnt final 20 seconds
here's a three by mitchell and he banks
it in why not
connects for the first denver basket is
remarkable efficiency
for jamal murray and watching mitchell
and murray
go at it in this series has been a
thrill
donovan mitchell he fires from three and
he rattles one home
what a start timeout michael malone he's
right with you chris webber for
six a couple of threes
spider mitchell gets his purse of the
night it's 15 to 8 utah
let's take to the basket by nicole
joaquin nice footwork right there by the
big man
mitchell a little hesitation at a finish
at the rim
spider this is how you follow that
offensive lineman into the paint
into the hands of murray gets a screen a
three-pointer is up and in
point game utah on top this is game six
utah denver see what the second unit
along with murray can do inside
the athletic plumber just clears the way
for murray for the nice layup the
blow-by by jamal murray now you're
healthy i think he's inspiring all his
teammates
and i'm not going to ask too much of
gary harris in transition here's murray
a little hesitation
and the reverse is good with the block
murray
finishes on the other end with a reverse
defensive rebound and murray on the
drive
murray is fouled and one than the
starters
they're more athletic with porter and
plumley they attack the basket more and
when you have a more athletic lineup or
you know guys that are more
up on that three-point shooter oh good
move murray boy
still able to keep control of the
basketball and a little oh murray he's
doing it all the only thing he's doing
eight for ten
22 points four for five from the
three-point line yeah
it's the first half still he's been
electrifying tonight he's got 22
already and now murray again oh
yeah he's sizing them up these two have
been going at it
and sometimes
mitchell turns the corner with milsap on
his hip and
mitchell with the layup key change you
talk about
shifts and talk about shifting getting
inside the euro step over the two big
fellas
trying to get it to go down he does
mitchell guarded by
monte morris harris back on the floor as
well
three-pointer is up for mitchell and
he's got it come on kind of had an
awkward step
into it but found the rhythm somewhere
on the way up murray
patient now he's got gobert on him step
back three on the way is good
a pleasure to have a defensive stopper
on your team just look at this look at
him moving his feet
and yeah i mean that's just better and
mitchell flies high for the rebound
nine point game utah trails eight minute
mark
in regulation and donovan mitchell
scored the basket and won
murray mitchell show once again we've
seen it all
series long so explosive and if one of
our eyes
grant a part of his game that he was not
known for knocking down threes
mitchell for three another big shot for
donovan mitchell
[Applause]
murray goes shot clock at three another
little floater is good
shot clock to seven mitchell's got grand
on it mitchell a little step back three
is good what a shot donovan mitchell
with a big hit
murray three-pointer is up and it's good
you have to credit
you have to credit james harden not many
people
in this league have their own moves we
can go through them the hook shot and
they
average nine and a half turnovers when
they get more than nine
they lose denver has been doing it on
the defensive end again
in in the three wins the jazz have had
under
10 turnovers turnover turns into a
three-pointer and
denver stretching this out to a 14-point
lead mitchell
with an answer jazz aren't dead yet
for 14 points and you want to answer
talking about ar clarkson
on the drive clarkson gives it up
mitchell
that's a three-pointer up it in donovan
mitchell with a sidestep
phil and murray is off the charts right
now
step back three on the way and he's got
another one
jamal murray man the step back
hand in the face murray
here jokic finding murray murray does he
got another one in him oh you bet he
does
and that might be the dagger for another
three
he said last year he did not play the
way that he wanted to play in the
playoffs he wanted to make amends for it
he came out here focused crazy i had
that same feeling
[Applause]
mitchell's been a little bit quiet until
now with the easy slam up
he's got to get going mitchell has only
taken five shots
has two points murray floater got it
jamal
jamal murray was looking for the call as
well
shot clock down to eight mitchell
double-teamed
forced that one up and got it to go if
you're a coach you say give it up you've
done your job you've done your job pass
the basketball
good shot good shot
got murray on the switch forced it up
and got it to go
donovan mitchell sensing something
brewing back in this ball game
trying to will his team this is good
defense tough shot by donovan mitchell
denver crowd the virtual crowd earlier
here in orlando the legend
yes the original mr triple double
and donovan mitchell got all the way to
the cup mitchell
foot on the gas pedal he's attacking
we're seeing much more
small small pick and roll as opposed to
big
and small setting the screen so now big
third quarter for donovan mitchell
that's the three and a half minute mark
here
a little bit of sauce off glass and good
teams look a little bit tired don't they
mark but they're getting good looks okay
they just have to trust your game i like
the way they're running their sets and
getting
quality looks forget tired mitchell ties
the game at 74.
he's you too how about this play
in the scene